Since we're working from
a command line only,
we don't have a graphical interface,
it only makes sense that we're currently
residing in some place on this computer.
We're within some directory in which
whatever we type will be executed from.
This is called our working directory.
Whenever you log into a Linux machine
you're automatically placed in your
user's home directory.
We can confirm this by
typing the command, pwd.
As you can see,
the result of this is /home/vagrant.
Let's unpack this a little bit.
The slash is the root
level of the file system.
It's the absolute highest you
can go in a Linux file system.
Everything on the machine
is in some way,
a child of the route level, usually
through a variety of other directories.
Home is a directory you'll find
within all Linux systems, and
it houses all the home directories
of each user with a few exceptions.
If we cd into this directory and
then list its contents,
we'll see that there is a directory for
each user on this machine,
including our current user, vagrant.
So let's go back into our own home
directory and see what's there.
This is our personal
space to store stuff, but
the operating system has already
placed a few files there for us.
If we just run ls we
won't get any results, so
we'll need to provide a few flags
to ls to modify it's behavior.
We'll add the -a flag,
which tells it to show all the files,
including hidden ones.
On a Linux system, any file that begins
with a dot is considered a hidden file.
We're going to add one more
flag to the ls command.
That is the l flag, which will list
the results in long format, and
provide a bit more information.
Now, there's a lot of info here, and
we'll eventually go over most of it.
For now, I want you to just
focus on the first character and
the names themselves.
If the first character is a d,
that's a directory.
If it's a dash, that's a file.
So you can see here that the .ssh and
.cache are both directories.
The rest of these are files.